quick question now that we're chatting
with one another yeah
do you like hot food do i like
hell yes i like hot food me too
and when my food is hot you know what i
like i like it to stay hot
conan are you saying that we have a new
sponsor with a product that addresses
this very issue
just in time for the holidays andy
that's exactly what i'm saying
hey what's up today ah i'm just thinking
about this morning
it happened again what well
i'm sitting down to eat my flapjacks
god damn it and i got distracted
so i have to abandon my stack of
pancakes to answer the goddamn door
and what do you think i returned to
after that
god damn ups guy makes my blood boil
all right calm down maybe santa will
bring you something to fix this terrible
problem
like what merry christmas
flapjackie introducing the flapjackie
the first ever down ski jacket
specifically designed to fit over a
stack of flapjacks
to keep them warm good hot pancakes
[Music]
i'll get it of course you will
[Music]
the flapjacky flapjack warming jacket
with syrup wicking interior
because cold flapjacks are a fake worse
than death
oh hi mom yeah i'm just eating some
pancakes that are probably still
[Music]
warm